I have a football chance to play with
these two champions and above all I really loved
doing that
I think there is a new
career it's a shame that I saw that
too late I could never do
roland garros three  celebrities
3 tennis challenge 3 physical challenge a grand
final
welcome strength late it was match
season 3 player selections
guillaume pley one meter eighty
five animators comedians the little
princes be a poster in sports
christophe michalak 1 m 83
pastry chefs sos autism  the reverse see you
tomorrow like sit ins and would be one
meter fifty and maurice it was
happiness a perfect mastery of the big
none level 3 the rhythm scale the
smash choice of the coach
pauline parmentier one meter seventy
seven young retricycle ilife champion  of the
world cédric pioline to put 90
professional tennis player
do the gypsy wall
polhenri nature 1 m 85 former pro player
10 sport and more backhand jumped to tomorrow
physical challenge
the  rhythm scale another challenge to
go from one channel to another as
quickly as possible by taking the most
correct answers to the quiz in one minute that's
why the skipping rope you know it does
n't seem to look if it continues
to agree always on the  tennis is a
question on the subject beware the
challenge begins in three 2 1 go the
fabric around the handle of the rackets is
called tantad fabrics and not the
women's singles cut and the
duras daisy cut it's true at the
new england coach the  cup of the musketeers
weighs 10 kg yes true record of aces in
only one match and of 37 c true false 215
France had approximately one million
licensees in tennis it is necessary in short
what tennis underwater is an
Olympic sport since 2005 must  more than
fifty thousand balls were used
for the tournament in 2018 true brothers it
is recommended to create during
matches to show your enthusiasm
well yes of course it is true but it is false
ah it is strictly forbidden to
bring back spare rackets and the
French tennis federation celebrated
its 100th anniversary in 2020 yes in short the
first editions of the tournament were played
on sand
the final of the men's singles of rank
garros is traditionally played on
Sundays it's true yes it's  true the
break point announces the players' tea party
that's why not yes I'm going
true false false false totally false
that's nonsense what I did 9
see this time I have the impression that the
shampoos finished it ends in serpentine
and manon lescaut
it's a fish it's good to be in
pain spite of this match of 6 and 10 the
smash the match is with powerful blows
playing above the head
five matches easily reaches the  200
km/hour at the professional level
for this challenge you have 10 stray balls
in the most matches possible tax
match in montredon fax match after rebound
there I send it to you easy you have
a robot,
that's it, that's the challenge  starts in
three years all round  would come with the
ball it will be easier to manage these
bouncing is no yeah it doesn't matter
ouch ouch ouch ah no I put it
custom made custom
yes well done yes damage damage froze
more points in the sun the revolt
she rebounds she goes back we go yes and
to play super that yeah not fat not
serious she is bad for ipod matches
tetouan pleasure smashes the seamaster
bravo we give it to the event
so it feels good to the red hats saw
her real bravo too  class a gift
but coach is there says riboud and it
feels so good we feel transcended as soon as
we play was very good I
spat it all out there why the caramel nuggets
the scores
yeah seven out of ten describes this roof
chances  beginners let's take stock
of the scores I want to do a real
frau service to see a man is
reached it's unplayable